President Trump loves a parade in fact
he was so impressed with Frances
Bastille Day event last year he wants
one in Washington but national security
correspondent Jennifer Griffin tells us
might not be so easy
president Trump came up with the idea
for a military parade while visiting
France during Bastille Day last July
seeing the tanks and the military
hardware and marching soldiers on the
champs elysées he has repeatedly
wondered why the US does not have such a
military parade along Pennsylvania
Avenue when the president visited the
Pentagon on January 18th he mentioned
the idea to the Joint Chiefs that's when
the Pentagon realized this was a
directive we're all aware in this
country of the president's affection and
respect for the military we've been
putting together some options we'll send
them up to the White House for decisions
we haven't made a final decision the
president simply exploring different
ways that he can highlight and show the
pride that we have in the military the
blowback from military veterans and
Democrats was immediate retired Major
General Paul Eaton a vote vets org wrote
Donald Trump has continually shown
himself to have authoritarian tendencies
and this is just another worrisome
example Democrat Adam Smith of the House
Armed Services Committee called it self
aggrandizing and a misuse of military
time and energy it's not something we've
done in America many fear that the US
will look like the authoritarian regimes
that use their militaries to prop up
their rule North Korea China and Russia
the tradition and France dates back to
Napoleon Republicans pushed back I think
it's entirely reasonable for the the
nation to be patriotic and to be able to
celebrate the people that are serving us
that 1% that actually serves us on
national defense the US had a military
parade on Pennsylvania Avenue after the
first Gulf War but that was after the
Pentagon had won a war another issue is
cost where would the money for such a
parade come from at a time when defense
budgets are under debate and
planes and tanks would have to be
shipped to Washington instead of
training potentially stretching and
already stretched military further
Shannon Jennifer Griffin from the
Pentagon thank you